Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Je viens du Liban.
C’est un tout petit pays
au bord de la Méditerranée.
Quand je dis aux gens que je viens de
ce pays, souvent, j’ai deux réactions.
Soit on me dit : « Ah ! mais
j’adore la cuisine libanaise »,
soit on me dit :
« Quel peuple résilient ! »
C’est vrai, en fait,
nous avons quinze ans de guerre civile,
hyperinflation,
une des plus grandes explosions
non nucléaires qui a touché la capitale,
une des plus grandes crises économiques
depuis la moitié du 19ᵉ siècle.
Et pourtant, on a cette réputation
de renaître de nos cendres.
Si cette métaphore était si inspirante,
pourquoi alors on ne s’en sort pas ?
Est-ce que ce n’est pas
dans cette résilience même
que se trouve une partie du problème ?
Je suis neuroscientifique, et quand
on aborde cette notion de résilience,
on considère que notre cerveau a évolué
pour garder un certain niveau d'équilibre.
Un stress, ce serait tout ce qui
nous éloigne de notre équilibre.
On a une réponse au stress
pour retrouver l’équilibre.
Et si on arrive à le retrouver, on peut
dire que notre système a été résilient.
Je vous donne un exemple.
Imaginez un ancêtre
qui est tranquille dans le champ,
il entend un bruit dans les arbres.
Il assume que c’est un prédateur -
il a intérêt -
et donc il va avoir une réponse au stress.
Il va avoir le cœur qui bat vite,
il va respirer plus fort,
il va transpirer.
Pourquoi ? Parce qu’il prépare
ses muscles à sauver sa peau.
Et dans cette course, notre ancêtre,
il n’a pas intérêt à dépenser de l’énergie
sur des fonctions secondaires,
non prioritaires.
Il ne va pas draguer, il ne va pas
siester, il ne va pas digérer,
il ne va pas réparer ses tissus.
S’il se blesse,
il ne va pas regarder sa blessure.
Parce que, logiquement,
à quoi ça sert, si jamais tu es en danger
de survie, de regarder ta blessure ?
Il ne va pas se poser
des questions existentielles.
Suis-je la meilleure version de moi-même ?
Pourquoi je vis ?
Tout ça, ça va paraître non prioritaire
et pourtant ce n’est pas grave
parce que ça va durer quelques minutes.
Soit il a fait le repas du prédateur,
soit il a échappé.
En tout cas, une fois
que ce stress est passé,
il peut retrouver l’équilibre
et ses fonctions reprennent.
On peut dire que notre ancêtre
a fait preuve de résilience.
Le problème, c’est que
notre cerveau ne fait pas de différence
entre un stress physique
et un stress psychologique.
Ça veut dire là, par exemple, si je perds
le fil de mes idées devant vous,
je vais avoir le cœur qui bat,
je vais respirer,
je vais avoir les mains moites,
les joues rouges
parce que mon corps pense
qu’il y a des prédateurs dans la salle.
Par contre, ce serait absurde
que je me mette à courir,
(Rires)
parce qu’en fait, il n’y a pas de
différence entre votre jugement,
votre possible jugement de moi-même,
entre une exclusion sociale,
l’incertitude, la perte de contrôle,
et une blessure physique.
Alors imaginer que nos stress
psychologiques durent
des semaines, des mois,
et que notre réponse au stress
met de la même façon en veille
nos fonctions physiologiques prioritaires,
ça devient un peu aisé de comprendre
pourquoi nos stress psychologiques
nous rendent malade.
Alors on a une réponse au stress
non adaptée qui presque nous tue.
Ce sont des maladies cardio-vasculaires,
du diabète, des cancers,
de maladies immunitaires qu’on meurt.
Alors qu’est-ce qu’on fait ?
Comment on guérit ?
Si je pose la question à des guides
ou des coachs de développement personnel,
ils vont dire : « Respire,
(Rires)
médite, prends en charge ta santé mentale
par la nutrition, le sommeil,
l’exercice. »
Vous avez des ateliers qui
vous apprennent à dire non,
des ateliers qui vous apprennent à rire,
à vous débarrasser des personnes toxiques.
Bref, vous avez tout ce que
vous pouvez imaginer aujourd’hui
comme stratégie pour reprendre
le contrôle sur nos émotions.
Et c’est ce qu’on propose aussi
aux personnes qui souffrent d’éco-anxiété
ou de burn-out professionnel :
trouver un moyen d’aller bien.
Et à première vue, franchement,
pourquoi pas ?
C’est vrai que nous avons la capacité
d’agir sur notre discours interne
et de se dire que je peux agir
sur ma santé physique et mentale.
Même la pensée positive,
qu’on fustige, fonctionne des fois.
Là, par exemple, je peux me dire :
« Ce n’est qu’une conférence,
ma mère m’aimera quand
même, quoi qu’il arrive. »
Ça va réduire ma réponse au stress -
c’est un peu ce que je me suis dit
avant de rentrer, d’ailleurs. (Rires)
Mais derrière cette apparence noble
et louable, il y a des effets pernicieux.
Parce que,
quand vous croyez que votre résilience
provient de vos pratiques individuelles,
vous pouvez finir par croire
que vous êtes libre,
donc que vous attribuez
à vous-même et aux autres
une liberté qui vous détache du reste.
Et donc vous finissez par croire
que vous êtes responsable
de ce que vous êtes
et de ce que vous allez devenir.
Pourquoi pas ? Franchement,
ça nous donne un aspect prometteur
que nous pouvons agir sur nous-même,
mais ça peut nous mener à une obsession
de considérer les enjeux sociaux
en termes d’obstacles internes
et donc de psychologiser
ce qui ne tient pas de la psychologie
parce que tout ne tient pas
de votre psychologie intérieure.
Notre santé mentale ne naît pas du vide.
On ne peut pas considérer
que le traumatisme de guerre
de mes proches libanais,
l’éco-anxiété ou le burn-out professionnel
comme un rhume qu’on a attrapé parce qu’on
s’est baladé au vent sans bien se couvrir.
Cette façon d'aborder la santé mentale et
la résilience comme un concept individuel
finit par blâmer l’individu,
nous détourner des structures et ne nous
inviter qu’à agir sur notre état d’esprit.
Mais nos cerveaux sont façonnés
par la société et si la société va mal,
il est tout à fait normal
que nous allions mal.
Et quand on va mal
parce que la société va mal,
on a besoin de plus
que de penser positivement.
Sinon ce serait comme
si je disais à mon ancêtre :
« Tourne-toi, regarde, l’ancêtre,
regarde les autres, regarde ton prédateur,
et engage
une communication non-violente. »
(Rires)
Ou si je dis à une personne
qui souffre d’éco-anxiété :
« Tu sais, les forêts qui brûlent,
ce n’est qu’une métaphore
de tes échecs amoureux. »
Ou à une personne qui souffre
de burn-out professionnel
qu’il faut qu’elle connecte
avec son enfant intérieur
pour qu’elle comprenne
la colère qu’elle vit
face au harcèlement moral qu’elle subit.
Ou carrément à une personne
qui a une fracture à la jambe
de prendre un anti-douleur puissant,
comme ça, elle peut marcher
comme si de rien n’était.
C’est là où la résilience
devient dangereuse,
quand c’est une quête d’aller bien,
mais qui ignore la source du mal,
quand les pratiques
de développement personnel
vont réduire votre douleur subjective
mais sans guérir la source du mal.
Nous avons besoin de plus que d’aller bien
parce qu’aucune étreinte aux arbres
ne va sauver nos forêts brûlées,
mais une réflexion radicale et collective
de nos modes de production
et de consommation.
Et aucune retraite spirituelle
ne va apaiser mes amis libanais,
mais un arrêt de la corruption
et une reconstruction de tissu social.
Et aucune séance de yoga
ne va être vraiment de l’aide
pour une personne qui souffre
de burn-out professionnel
si on ne réfléchit pas
au milieu du travail
pour le rendre aligné
avec notre besoin d’autonomie,
de reconnaissance et de respect
de notre valeur humaine.
L’empereur stoïcien
Marc-Aurèle, il dit que
ce qui n’est pas bon pour un essaim
d’abeilles n’est pas bon pour l’abeille.
Vous n’allez jamais voir une abeille
tranquille dans un champ
alors que son essaim brûle.
Alors, il est temps que
nous considérions la santé mentale
comme quelque chose qui n’est pas réduit
à notre cerveau et à notre corps,
mais qui prend en compte l’environnement
dans lequel nous vivons.
Est-ce que je suis en train de vous
dire de ne pas vous soigner ?
Au contraire, dans un monde aussi abîmé
qui vous invite à vous surmener,
à préférer le succès au bonheur,
c’est un droit de nous soigner.
D’ailleurs, le mouvement de self-care,
ou de soin de soi,
est né dans les cercles d’activistes
afro-américains des années 80,
mais après, il a été récupéré
par le broyeur du capitalisme,
des industries de fitness, de bien-être.
Aujourd’hui, on parle
d’économie de l’expérience
qui dit que,
plus vous faites des expériences,
et plus vous vous approchez
de la meilleure version de vous-même.
Et donc c’est devenu une injonction
à devenir des personnes optimisées.
Or, nous devons récupérer
le droit de nous reposer.
Pas parce que ça nous rend
plus profond ou plus lucide,
mais parce que nous pouvons.
Un enfant, par exemple, qui transvase
de l’eau d’un vase à l’autre,
il ne le fait pas parce que ça permet
de développer sa motricité fine,
il le fait parce qu’il en a envie.
Et nos pratiques de soin ne doivent pas
être coûteuses et sophistiquées,
parce que le monde nous offre
plein d’opportunités simples.
Et peut-être que nous n’avons rien
inventé de plus efficace
que les formes invisibles de solidarité.
Prenez par exemple un primate.
Vous le mettez dans une pièce,
vous le stressez.
Au bout d'un moment, il a des ulcères.
Mais s’il subit le même stress
en présence d’autres primates,
il a moins d'ulcères.
Et pour nous, les études sont unanimes :
que vous ayez une maladie cardiovasculaire
ou un discours à faire devant un public,
la présence de vos proches
vous rend la vie plus douce.
Alors peut-être, en attendant que
nous rendions le monde plus juste,
plutôt que nous nous renfermions
sur nous-même
dans des pratiques de développement
personnel invitant
à nous replier sur notre fonctionnement,
on peut plutôt nous évader de nous-même,
nous oublier un peu,
nous prendre moins au sérieux,
et retrouver une simple douceur
dans le fait que nos destins individuels
tirent des racines interminables
vers l’expérience des autres.
Donc nous soigner, oui -
je ne dis rien contre,
au contraire, c’est nécessaire -
mais nos problèmes, ou en tout cas
leur majorité, sont structurels.
Et donc nous n’avons qu’une issue :
les résoudre collectivement.
Peut-être que ce que je vous
dis vous paraît compliqué,
parce que, oui, c’est plus simple
d’appeler une chamane
qui fait des pratiques amazoniennes
mais qui s’appelle Alexandra,
(Rires)
ou Corinne, et qui habite dans le Lot.
Mais en fait,
ce n’est pas vrai, parce que
c’est libérateur de se dire
que ce n’est pas à vous tout seul
de trouver les solutions.
Et aussi, c’est libérateur de se dire que
vos épreuves n’arrivent pas
nécessairement pour une raison.
Ce ne sont pas nécessairement des leçons.
Et donc nous n’avons pas à nous élever,
à devenir plus lucide
et à considérer que ces épreuves sont là
pour nous apprendre quelque chose.
Parce que ça rajoute
à nos épreuves la culpabilité
de ne pas en faire des tremplins
vers des meilleures versions de soi.
Et enfin, c’est un grand soulagement
de se dire que nous n’avons pas
à nous concilier avec un monde abîmé,
qu’il est légitime qu’on soit en colère,
qu’on ait peur, qu’on soit triste, qu’on
soit en manque, qu’on soit son deuil,
que ce ne sont pas des signes que vous
n’avez pas encore trouvé la bonne thérapie
et ce ne sont pas des névroses privées,
ce sont au contraire
des réactions utiles et saines
à un monde qui ne va pas.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)